the pipeline function
the pipeline function is the most high
level api of the transformers library
it regroups together all the steps to go
for more texts
to usable predictions the weather used
is at the core of a pipeline but the
pipeline also includes all the necessary
pre-processing
since the model does not expect texts
but number
as well as some post processing to make
the output of the model human readable
let's look at the first example with the
sentiment analysis pipeline
this pipeline performs text
classification on a given input
and determines if it's positive or
negative
here it attributed the positive label on
the given text
with a confidence of 95 percent
you can pass multiple texts to the same
pipeline which will be processed
and passed through the model together as
a batch
the output is a list of individual
results in the same order as the input
text
here we find the same label on score for
the first text
and the second text is church negative
with a confidence of 99.9 percent
the xeroshot classification pipeline is
a more general text classification
pipeline
it allows you to provide the labels you
want here
we want to classify our input text along
the labels education
politics and business the pipeline
successfully recognizes
it's more about education than the other
labels with a confidence of 84
moving on to other tasks the text
generation pipeline will autocomplete a
given prompt
the output is generated with a bit of
randomness so it changes each time you
call the generator object
on a given prompt up until now
we've used the pipeline api with the
default model associated to each task
but you can use it with any model that
has been retrained or fine-tuned on this
task
going on the model hub again fest.go
slash models
you can filter the available models by
task
the default adult used in our previous
example was tpt2
but there are many more models available
and not just in english
let's go back to the text generation
pipeline and load it with another model
distilled gpg 2. this is a lighter
version of gpd2
created by the early phase team when
applying the pipeline to a given prompt
we can specify several arguments such as
the maximum length of the generated text
or the number of sentences we want to
return since there is some randomness in
the generation
generating text by using the next word
in a sentence while the retraining
objective of gpd2
the field mass pipeline is a retraining
objective of pert
which is to guess the value of mass
words
in this case we ask the two most likely
values for the missing words
according to the model and get
mathematical or computational
as possible answers another task
transformers model can perform is to
classify each word in a sentence
instead of the sentence as a word one
example of this
is named entity recognition which is a
task of identifying entities
such as persons organizations or
locations
in a sentence here
the model correctly finds the person
silva
the organization again face as well as a
location
brooklyn inside the input text
the grouped entities equal two arguments
used is to make the pipeline group
together the different words linked to
the same entity
such as ugging and face here
another task available with the pipeline
api is extractive question answering
providing a context on a question the
model will identify the span of text in
the context
containing the answer to the question
getting short summaries of very long
articles is also something the
transformers library can help with
with the summarization pipeline
finally the last task supported by the
pipeline api
is translation here we use a french
english model found on the model hub
to get the english version of our input
text
here is a brief summary of all the tasks
we've looked into in this video
try them out through the inference
widgets in the modern hub